محمد العويس حارس مرمى المنتخب السعودي
رجل المباراه وحديث الاعلام الرياضي
العالمي لم يبخل بقطره عرق حتى النهايه
واستحق ارشادات مشجعي كره القدم في كل
مكان وبكل لغات العالم ضغط شديد يحمله على
ظهره قبل الممتعه الهجوم الكبير بسبب
تذبذب مستواه ترصد من بعض الجماهير
لاخطائه في المباريات الوديه وانتقادات
للمدرب الفني السعودي هذه رينار الذي اصر
عليه حارسا اساسيا الاخضر السعودي في
المباراه الاولى للمونديال يرد العويس
بادائه البطوله يتصدى لخمس كرات با
ويقفك الجبل طوال اكثر من 100 دقيقه العمر
ويخمد البركان الارجنتيني بمنتهى الثبات
راينا العويس ايضا يخرج من مرماه ليعوض
تقدم الدفاع ويتدخل على الكره ليافتكها
ببراعه قبل انفراد مهاجم الارجنتين
بالمرمى ويحبط اكثر من هجمه واحده ومحققه
للتسجيل محمد العويس رجل المباراه الاولى
في مشوار السعوديه بالمونديال والاعلى
تقيما تبقى لجميع منصات الرياضيه العالميه
تجاوز الاختبار الاصعب بجداره وينتظره
تحديا اخران في المجموعه امام ليفاندوفسكي
والمنتخب البولنديه يوم السبت والمكسيك في
المباراه الاخيره بالمجموعه